herkes
Buna
Bence
kanın
önceki
[Müzik]
şehir
kazanmak
senin içinde
Y
bir grupla birlikte olacağız
burada
Evet
[Müzik]
reklamı yaparken varız
Peki
[Müzik]
hayat vereceğim
ve sen
Evet
[Müzik]
onun için bir onurdur
herkes
mevcut değil
Merhaba
[Müzik]
Güneyde
Y
benim için
ödev yaparım
ve yeniden
artı
koşullar nerede
[Müzik]
Merhaba
2039'da almıyoruz
D
tüm dünyaya müdahale
iyileşmek için
içindeki en yüksek element
kan
Ey
önceki
[Müzik]
23 dakika
çünkü bu durmuyor
ef
ama neden kullandığını söylüyorum
bir arada
ve yaşıyorum
Y
hiçbir şeysiz
Evet
Barış içinde
Bence
gittiğimizde
biz bir topluluğuz
verebilirim
Bence
inek öğrenci
Bu şehirde
Evet
arada sırada
D
[Müzik]
kim daha çok gider
inek öğrenci
artı
alan faizi yazdıktan sonra
daha fazlası için gidelim
Yapamam
Ey
[Müzik]
Evet
hak etmiyor
kar için
şimdi normal
D
[Müzik]
hareket halinde
nasıl yapamam
tamamen
yürüyüşçüler hakkında konuşuyorlar
nerede
onların tanrılarına döndüler
dedi
[Müzik]
ve ileri
nerede
27 dakika
insanlara
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
D
büyük bir gruptan çok üstün
Ne
[Müzik]
bir
zihinsel olarak hazırlanmak
o
kadar
[Müzik]
ve topluluklar
hayır seni yenemem
Evet
[Müzik]
çocuklar
sonra
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Dünyada
Evet
[Alkış]